If people were cars, fixing people problems would be easy.
Check the engine, find the cause of the trouble, replace the faulty part and move on.
But, people are not machines.
Focusing on problems and their causes...
...is a great way of getting cars back on the road...
...but it's not much use when you're trying to help people move forward.
Take Alex, he wants to step up to a higher management role...
...but he lacks confidence.
Some people might try to help Alex by asking why he feels this way.
Perhaps the answer lies in his past.
"When I was a child, a teacher humiliated me in front of the class."
Or...
"The other kids teased me."
But, concentrating on the causes of his problem...
...soon leaves Alex buried under an avalanche of painful memories.
He knows why he lacks confidence, but nothing in his life has changed.
...he still feels just the same.